[Music]  if  sometimes to do what's right we have to  be steady and give up the thing we want  the most even our dreams how am I  supposed to save the whole world you  can't think about saving the world you  have to think about saving one person so  you want to learn to be spider-man can  you teach me yes I can  to see the spark in you it's amazing  [Music]  time to swing  [Music]  you got to get better at this part of  the job I'm sad I'm intimidating I'm  gonna kill the light everyone in the  city stood in the water fields  overall mercy of Allah without  spider-man  this was their City it's my L  a page on  are you really friends with Peter Parker  breaking news spider-man saves the day  again remember what makes you different  is what makes you spider-man officer  love you I will never forget these words  with great power comes great  responsibility  this is my cat  my curse  Who am I  I'm spider-man  [Music]